Allahbar. Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
Shadwell.
[Silence]
was Oh,
Oh, no.
[Silence]
You're no
You're in for now.
[Silence]
When you're in
Allah long
[Silence]
Oh,
alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Abd Allah subhana wa ta'ala for put
Muslim was
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, mothers and sisters, we
thank Allah subhana tala for keeping us
alive one more day on the path of Islam
on theat
and allowing me and you to enter his
house and worship him in the manner that
pleases him. I ask Allah subhana tala to
accept from me and accept from you the
little we do in his path. Amen. And I
bear witness there is no deity worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is his last and final
messenger. For surely who Allah subhana
tala chooses to guide and misguide and
whoever chooses to misguide nik can
guide him back to the path and we seek
refuge in Allah from darkness of
ourselves and evil of deeds for Allah is
all knowing and allseeing what his
creation does. The last time we met for
the Judah, we talked about the three
kinds of naps each one of us have and
everybody has the naps within it and
it's not the nuffs cannot be described
as a soul because a soul is different
than what an is even when the mushik
when they went to to to the Jews and
they ban and they asked him they asked
them how can we test that sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is a true prophet of
Allah.
One of the questions they were given to
to
them was
ask about the and if he tells you
something about it he's not a true
prophet so they came and asked him and
there was questions besides that but he
asked them and the questions and they he
says as mentioned in the Quran he says
that I don't know anything about it it's
anram of Allahh and Allah has not given
me any knowledge of that so is what we
don't know what does it work we
don't know but it is not the ns that is
for sure that is something that we have
clear indications from both hadith and
and and and the and the narrations of
sallaihi wasallam so I want to make sure
that we clarify that one part because a
lot of times people say oh my soul is
this my soul feels that yes the soul
gets burdened it has a burden upon it if
we are not doing what Allah has told us
to do there is a constant struggle
within in your body, your soul is
fighting it because it knows what the
true path is. And when it doesn't get
that true path, when it does not get its
feed from the proper ways and the
nourishments of the Allah subhana tala,
then it fights you.
But what does Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has mentioned on the of im part
of his of us bringing our nefs ourselves
to be centered again and to feel at at
tranquility and ease is what wasam has
said. He mentions three conditions for
somebody who wants to taste
the be the the beauty of the iman or
taste the sweetness of iman. In other
words,
as mentioned mentioned in a in a hadith
mentioned by bkari it's copied in it. He
said that I heard say three things is
needed for us to taste the sweetness of
our iman of our faith.
What are those three things? First
is that Allah and his prophet
sallallah.aihi wasallam are the most
dearest things to him in this world
against every single thing. And on those
on that part of the narration, there are
several other narrations that are
available whereas sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has mentioned that none of you
truly believe until that person loves me
more than he loves his family, his kids,
his you know children, his mal his
everything. He does not truly have iman
until he loves me beyond that
point. What what does that love look
like? Is that love? I always say I
love and you know once a year I I attend
the gatherings of milad and I'm not
saying it's right or wrong. That's not
my topic today. So don't quote me either
way please. Or you know I go to and you
know we we have the discussion on and
I'm
okay that's it.
No, that's starting to come to close to
love toam by reading. But a true love of
is is that we take
whatasoolaham has told us to do and we
stay away from he has told us not to do
that's true form of
love right that's true form of love that
we have and the same goes in the in this
hadith let's go back to this hadith
of same thing for Allah subhanaa tala
that's the true form of love for Allah
subhanaa tala what Allah has put down as
his as his things that we need to be
following. We do that. What's the second
part? Second part is you love a person
for the sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
There is nothing else that you are you
are to have with that person except it
is for sake of truly of Allah subhana
tala. That that is a that's a hard
concept to swallow too because often at
times mashallah we see it I see it
because I observe a lot more than most
people realize you you you watch in in
gatherings or even after salah we're
congregating within our people that we
know it's the same group of people that
we always hang
out and you go say salam to them and you
were laughing and you know having a good
time alhamdulillah there's nobody
stopped you from that I'm not saying
it's
wrongs. But opening yourself up to other
brothers, going up and meeting
everybody, right? That takes us to
another,
right? You will not have iman until you
have love for each other.
and they say how can
we he said go say salam to
everybody and I've been saying that for
years by the way often at times we have
brothers in this community that we see
are traveling through or they're here
for two weeks or 3 weeks and nobody says
salam to
them it's our job as a community to say
everybody and part of the saying salam
is to actually go to the person and say
maf so you actually shake their hand and
say salam. That's the proper way of
saying so. So go up to people and say
salam to them. And the last part of the
hadith mentioning on the on the and by
the way it's it's written in the they
have a whole chapter that he has named
the the sweetness or the delight of the
faith and he
says and he hates going back to atheism
or disbelief as much as he hates going
to the hellfire.
basically saying that not turning our
back
on.
Now having said
that look at the life
of because his is the best pathway for
us to achieve what we want to
achieve. Now I read you the hadith that
is the sweetness of iman. Now, how can
we come to purify our souls, purify our
our our
nefs, not the soul, the nefs, how we
purify our nefs and
become, you know, steady on our feet for
the sake of Allah subhana
tala. I'm not going to go back to the
lastba. If you haven't heard the lastba,
go back and you can see it on YouTube
and Facebook. It's available in where I
mentioned the three types of naps we
have. But part of the today is for me to
draw your attention to a surah that we
often don't think about. And this is a
beautiful surah in the Quran. So much so
that it's in a me mentioned in authentic
narration. When the person came
to Wasallam and he
complained is leading a long
salah called Muad and this is by the way
this is Muad. You have to understand
this is the guy who knew
Quran. The Quran was flowing in him like
the blood flows in our
wings. Allah wasallam is his teacher.
this guy is asking mah readad Quran
on me. So this is somebody who has a
very high status among the companions of
sallallahu alaihi wasallam but he's
leading a salah on and it's long. So the
person in the back in the road left the
salah literally in the middle of the
salah the guy walks out. I'm giving you
the background so just you have an idea
what we're talking about. The guy leaves
the salah and some of the companions
notice him leaving the salah and they go
to say muad so and so left the salah
while you were leaving the salah and
says this guy is probably a kafir he's a
mushik he's kafir he left this
disbeliever there's two lessons to be
learned we should not use our tongue
sometimes we say things that we don't
mean we should be
careful so The person hears about this
from somebody else. They say listen was
heard about you leaving and he said you
are out of Islam. You are no longer a
Muslim. This person goes directly to
says explain to me what am I supposed to
do? We are people who are daily
laborers. We work with our hands. We are
in the fields all day doing all the
work. We live outside of Medina. And
please don't think today, you know,
you're going to come and say, "She
Madina is very big." Medina at that time
was not this big, man. Probably the
Haram, the Medina Haram, if you've been
to recently, Medina Haram, that was the
entire
city. That was the entire city. Probably
even less than that. Because if you go
today next to Haram, there's a masjid
that used to
use and that is now really up to the
haram.
Now, so he says,
We don't have time. We are tired all
day. We have to wake up early in the
morning and be at back out as
laborers leads a very long
salah. We can't stand. There was no way
I could stand behind him. So I left. So
calls and says these
words, are you creating a fitna in my
and not once he asked him three times
and of course realizes that this is
something that he made a mistake upon.
So tells read two
suras and
and in twoas read that surah and your
salah is good.
Alhamdulillah. And now don't come to me
and say, you know, we don't read them
every day. It's not I'm not saying that
you should have that every day. You
know, once in a while it's good to go
in. And by the way, our salah is not
that long either. So don't don't come
and complain. It's it's okay.
Alhamdulillah, it's perfectly
fine. We stick about a page and you
know, page of half, you know, something
some somewhere along a page and less
would be good. Inshallah. And by the
way, depends upon the person reading
salah too. Sometimes they read a long
chapter a long page but it's something
that people connect with.
Alhamdulillah. But this this surah this
surah surah is an amazing surah and we
have never paid attention to it in the
manner that needs to be paid attention
to right. So let's let's today look at
surah together for a little bit. I
actually had planned to to go you know
divulge into another topic but I thought
it was appropriate to mention this
before we start in that and inshallah
you know I don't have enough so
inshallah when I have twobas back to
back we'll talk about the topic so it's
a continuation not a a a a stop in the
middle so Allah subhana ta starts the
surah by taking the so by the way it's
15 ayat in this surah and it's a maki
surah
It was revealed in Mecca and from the
tenil center point of point of view when
the the surah was brought down
on it lines up somewhere the 26th surah
that was revealed upon him in the
maka and it starts with an amazing
thing. So first seven verses Allah
subhana t is just taking nonstop.
Allah subhana you will not find anywhere
else in the Quran in the same manner
where Allah subhana has taken sevens
back to back to back to back to explain
a single
point there's in the Quran we're not
saying there's not maybe two three four
in in a row. But seven back to back is
an amazing thing to
see. Consider the sun and the radiant
brightness.
When the the moon comes out when and
then the light of the sun then it be
reveals the world world to
you and when the night covers the the
the earth in
darkness and the and the sky and
everything that it's in
there and then and the earth and how we
spread it out.
Have you ever considered how the
beautiful earth has spread out
itself? Have you ever taken the time
when you're driving on the freeway,
especially if you're coming from
Valencia into the city of Tucson, have
you looked around you how there is a
round chain of mountains around the
whole city and the earth is flat in the
middle and Allah has stretched it out
further and
further. And then you drive from from
here to Phoenix and you see how the
earth is stretched out further and
further out. And Allah has used the
mountains just as nails to hold the
earth flat. I'm not saying this. Allahh
says that don't don't come to me and say
brother you said that. Allah says that I
Quran says that I didn't say
that. Allah is
taking
after and then he comes to the seventh
verse. Allahh
says and have you considered the human
self thes of the man how it is formed in
accordance what it is meant to be
as there is sevens Allah
takes to get to the point and what's the
point that he gets
to Allah says then we taught thes how it
is supposed to have the moral feelings
and it is the consciousness of Allahh
that has been put into
the we taught the both the good and the
bad thes knows both
sides and then we come to the to the
main point that Allah mentions in the
surah whoever has purified his soul
going to be in the best most happiest
states
When he used to recite the surah, when
he came upon the
worst, his head would lift up towards
the sky and he would make the dua to
Allah subhanaa
tala. He will raise his head towards the
heavens and make this dua. Who is making
this dua?
you and
measool the purest human being to walk
upon the earth. A human being that Allah
said everything is forgiven for you. And
he's asking for what? A purification of
his
nefs.
Allah. Oh Allah give my my nefs tawa.
Give it fearing of Allah. Mindfulness of
Allah subhana tala.
purify it because you're the best
purifiers. You are responsible for my
soul and you also for my ns and also you
are the master of it. You own it. My n
is for you too. You own it ya
Allah. And in some narrations
mention and by the way in some
narrations the dua is a little bit
different but same words are used just a
different form where it's front and back
but
mentions it accordingly as as I've
recited to you and in some narration
it's
mentioned
that voice would get louder every time
he recite this dua the the surah when he
came to the ayah
Basically, Allah is saying, "Whoever has
purified his soul is the person who's
going to win and whoever destroyed
it is going to
lose." And the Saha kind of if you
translate it, you know, verbatim, it
literally means that you took something
and you buried it something in the dark.
You buried it in darkness. So your your
neph is kind of tucked away.
in in in the in the
darkness where it doesn't have the
light and the narration mention's voice
would get
louder to make the dua to Allah subhana
tala and then Allahh shifts gears and he
talks about the tribe of Tammud and
how they were they were the people who
Allahh sent his upon But those are the
two verses I want you to focus on
because that is where Allah subhana t
has given us a a recipe to fix
ourselves. And not only that that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
taught us the dua of how to to ask Allah
subhana wa tala for that for that
victory. And that is a true
victory. That's the true success in the
world. Everything else that we see is
temporary. Everything has a season and
season is over. And we see that rebirth
and dying off. You might have a healthy
tree in your yard that produces oranges.
It does not produce oranges all of its
life or every day for rest of the life
that a tree is upon standing up on its
feet or you know is in ground so to
speak. But it has a cycle.
After the cycle, the the flowers are
formed into those that are pollinated
are formed into a fruit. A lot of the
flowers fall on the ground. Nothing
becomes of it. And
eventually those oranges that are on
there also die. The leaves shed. The
plants re the plant regenerates itself.
It goes through a winter or a dormant
time and then the spring comes again and
it grows. So as such our lives are going
through the same cycle and eventually
one day this will be it for us and the
only thing that we take with us is that
work that we have done in this world to
to upon ourself upon
us. I ask Allahh to make us from the
people when they hear the words of the
Quran or the hadith they listen to it
and they penetrates their heart and they
become acting upon it. I ask Allahh to
make us from the of who unites hearts
and not divide hearts. I ask Allahh to
make us from the of the
and the true form and not divides it.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
We will finish at this inshallah for the
for the but I want to remind myself
again that we both we all of us have a
lord and we have to return to him one
day and a return to Allah subhanaa tala
has to be in best form. So we ask Allah
subhanaa tala that he does not take us
from this earth until he himself is
happy and satisfied with us. And when he
does take us from this earth that are we
we are in the submission of Allah
subhana tala and that last words that
roll off our tongue are
of and that Allah subhana ta on the day
of judgment he does not put us through
the the checking and the balancing of
the books but he enters into paradise
without any
accountability.
[Silence]
for Allah.
Allah
[Silence]
Sudan.
for
Jenn. When they become
[Silence]
Can you guys move forward please?
There's people standing on the back
sides.
for
[Silence]
Please turn your lines from all the gaps
in between. May Allah have mercy upon
us. Amen.
Allah. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
[Silence]
for the
for them. Be him.
[Silence]
forb Allah ham.
Allahbar Allahbar.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
Alche. foreign
[Silence]
Allahbar send me Allah.
Allahbar Allah I ke.
[Silence]
All right, just a couple of quick
announcements. First and foremost, we
were requested to make a dua for a
brother who's going through a lot of
health issues and and some surgeries.
they have chosen not to reveal their
name. We ask Allah subhana tala to
provide cure for all the illnesses for
the brother and may Allah provide him
full
shif and all those brothers and sisters
in this community who are suffering with
any illness, may Allah subh remove it.
May Allah provide them cure. May Allah
keep them healthy inshallah. And then
the Muslim overall
inshallah. just a couple of quick
reminders. The only authorized boxes for
donations zakat saddaka mid donations
are bolted to the wall upstairs and
downstairs. If somebody is asking you to
put in a separate box or there's a
separate box, please do not put that
money in those boxes. Those are not mid
approved. We don't know where it's
going. So for your safety and us just
make it sure if you have somebody who
has a genuine need inshallah bring them
to us and we can help them out with
whatever help aid they need
inshallah. Inshallah second thing I
mentioned last week and I mentioned
again inshallah we've had some issues
with shoes getting exchanged maybe and
so forth. I'm going to be kind enough to
just say that that's it. So please be be
aware when you are taking your shoes
from that. if if my hand is forced
further, I will produce video clips and
pictures inshallah to post around. I
don't want to do that. So be mindful.
It's the B of Allah subhana tala. It's
the house of Allah. It's not my house or
your house. So something is taken from
the house of Allahh. The the punishment
will be accordingly inshallah. So make
sure you're aware you're taking your own
shoes inshallah. And if you're afraid
that your shoes are a little too nice,
wear something else from the car
inshallah. That's fine. All right. Okay.
, Ignar Relief is outside. If you know
somebody who can benefit from some of
the food or stuff outside that's
available, please feel free to either
call the person or bring them down here.
And summer school is available for
Rahma Academy. It's posted on the wall.
Sunday for Sunday school. Inshallah. The
announcement is coming soon. We'll have
it ready for you soon. Inshallah. ,
donate generously on your way out.